mortgage affordability tests in in 2022
with things have been different I know
they've probably improved
um the the nature of those charts right
now but would they have been even more
resilient had you actually left it in
place for a little bit longer
well I'll start off I think
two points on the first part I'll come
on to the test withdrawal points
um I mean the first part it sounds the
first part is the support John just made
which is you know what what macro
Prudential policy particularly the
mortgage as you just mentioned it I mean
the mortgage policies that we adopted
back you know nearly 10 years ago now
actually
um have done is that they have limited
the number of people who are going to
face you know the extreme you know pain
and stress of this uh as a consequence
the second point to make is is a
macroeconomic point that we do have of
course much lower unemployment in this
country we have yeah we have a much
stronger labor markets we're having to
deal with that on another front but on
this front of course it is it is helping
a lot in terms of the stress that houses
are seeing on the the withdrawal of the
test I mean the answer is no actually
and the reason is the reason we would
withdrew the test is that we we had
three tests essentially applying at that
time so there was the LTI flow limit as
we call it which is an FPC measure which
is which is still there and then we had
two affordability tests one was the fpcs
and the other was the FCA it's
and the consequence of all the work that
our staff did in assessing that was that
is that the two of the two affordability
tests and actually also the sum of the
free tests if you like
um was meant that the two the two of we
didn't need two affordability tests one
one was doing the job
um and that's why we would drew the FBC
one because we felt that actually the
combination of the FCA one which has to
be there under under rules and the LTI
float limit test did the job so you know
from the point of view we do obviously
have a Keen Eye on regulatory efficiency
um we felt that did it